what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin super pumped
for this six hundredth episode we will
be talking about timeless spiritual
wisdom we have Dustin to burner joining
us on the show hi doesn't Alan hi thanks
for coming out there froak that's a joy
to be here thank you for having me such
a joy for you to join us and I'm very
grateful that we were able to meet
thanks to the meditation retreat that
was with Dan Brown yeah and that Michael
McCullough was an initiate or bringing
me into that and I'm so grateful that
that those teachings are that we will be
talking about them throughout this
conversation and that you yourself have
become a teacher and so I'm so pumped
for those that don't know the TSA's
background he is a visionary leader
author meditation teacher founder of
bright alliance and recognized expert in
world religions who has committed his
life to making timeless spiritual wisdom
relevant and accessible for a rapidly
changing global society you can find his
main link in the bio below Dustin deeper
Netcom and also his Amazon profile with
all of his books
I highly recommend checking those out
Dustin let's start things off with we
have been so fascinated with
understanding the nature of this reality
what do you think is the nature of the
reality great good question let me start
by saying congratulations 600 episodes
is a huge feat that takes a lot of will
and courage and capacity so
congratulations really amazing
600
nature of rally what do you think what's
nature of reality
I certainly have some answers yeah I'd
love to say something about it what do
you think let's nature reality we were
mentioning us a little bit before we
started these like four words a
holographic fractal learning simulation
is this just a funny like hopefully if
good I think described yet yeah you know
we all have different experiences of
reality we enact reality moment by
moment according to the particular views
and perspectives that we take those
perspectives are influenced by the
culture that we inherit they're
influenced by our developmental level
they're influenced by the spiritual
orientation we take to life so we all
have quite different views about the
nature of reality but from my own
practice and from the many amazing
teachers that I've learned from things
tend to point towards a reality that is
unbounded meaning that there's no
separation and no limits that allow
reality a reality that's ultimately
deeply whole meaning that we're not in a
world where separation division and
suffering is something that's inevitable
but there's protected perspectives that
we can take where that limitless
unbounded wholeness is one that becomes
not only a temporary state that we
experience but one that can be
permanently established as part of our
true nature so those are the teachings
I'm really interested in hopefully we
can talk more about it today a timeless
unbounded wholeness making that the norm
right on a moment-to-moment basis
exactly so you know basically one of the
things that I've found so incredible is
that you know many of us have had these
peak experiences throughout our lives so
one of my dear friends and mentors Ken
Wilber
often says part of the task of spiritual
practice is taking these temporary
States and developing permanent traits
and if we can over time train our mind
and train the perspectives that we take
in such a way that unbounded wholeness
becomes the way that we experience day
to day living then it's more we become a
master of our moments moment Experion
rather than just an athlete who has
temporary flow States or Peaks
experiences so for me the stabilization
of those types of recognition is what
the game is all about not just moment to
moment experiences oh man
the game being so about the
stabilization of these types of states
of awareness I think is such a crucial
part and we have all of these different
options for feeling timeless unbounded
wholeness all of these different options
and we get to pick which ones we want to
play with and experience these different
options on a buffet for this Rikka
muting with this one and for certain
ones of us will like certain options on
the buffet more than others and so it's
like we all have different combinatorics
of the options for what feels best for
us to try to get to a moment-to-moment
state of that timeless unbounded
wholeness
but there's dangerous along the path is
dangerous I am my you know have two main
mentors Ken Wilber and Dan Brown I'm
sure we'll talk about it in certain
points but I remember being in a retreat
with Dan Brown and he was teaching with
a Tibetan teacher named Rahab Tokarev
Bechet and on the retreat Rob compared
today's spiritual sort of buffet to use
her sort of your language I was sort of
this spiritual fleamarket and one of the
troubles with the spiritual flee marker
one of the dangers is that you go around
a new sample everything we don't
actually take anything deep and it's
been my experience that there's a lot of
sample errs and a lot of people who are
picking sort of what feels good in the
moment and what tastes good in the
moment
but there are very few people who are
willing to make the sacrifice to take
something all the way to its full
culmination and completion so in my
perspective I really agree with the
Zen's thing that's that if you chase two
rabbits you don't catch any you don't
catch either it's the idea that you have
to sort of pick something and go really
deep into it of course along the way you
can supplement and complement with
different paths and perspectives but
it's really important that you drill the
well all the way to water Wow
chase two rabbits you don't catch any
and also drill the well deep enough so
we have to be careful using too many
metaphors here exactly exactly and what
I find today you know I have a lot of
exposure particularly here in Silicon
Valley and in sort of the larger bay
area and I find that a lot of people are
really genuine about their spiritual
seeking and their spiritual path
sometimes what happens is that people
when things start to get difficult or if
they feel let down by a particular
teacher or there's things that happened
that they sort of give up and they pick
something else that feels good in the
moment certainly I see this with people
who are state chasing around entheogens
and other things is that they have a lot
of really positive experiences but there
hasn't been a way in which they've made
that part of that their everyday life
and certainly there are people working
with us who have done that but there's a
lot of people who haven't Wow
so it's equally as important for when we
are find ourselves adventuring into
consciousness in this world to I to both
identify timeless spiritual wisdom and
also make it the most common baseline of
our moment-to-moment experience there's
a very simple model that's been really
influential in my life and that's a
model that looks at spiritual
intelligence Paul Tillich as a
theologian a number of years ago a
couple few decades ago he defined
spirituality as that which is of
ultimate concern
his work developed in such a way where
where another theorist named James
Fowler took his work and started to say
are there actually stages of faith
developer stages of spiritual realm that
develop over time
and to your point what we find is that
spirituality and spiritual realization
if we want to talk about something about
that's deeply experiencial
has to be the underpinning or the fabric
that we orient our whole life around I
used to say the escape velocity of the
ego is that you have to give everything
to it so you have to actually want
spirituality get to want realization
more than anything else or else we're
taking refuge in rainbows as I say which
we can talk about Wow the ultimate
focus of our adventure into
consciousness is spirituality and making
that a norm in our social fabric where
it's fun and it's playful and it's on
and it's happening your flea market
analogy you know I'm just yeah just say
that I was gonna say it's happening on
the street corners just like our fast
food is happening on the street corners
but like you said not chasing 7,000
rabbits but maybe you know there is but
their spiritual pluralism is extremely
important but also finding what works so
after sampling finding what's working
and then kind of drilling down for water
exactly that so so again mixing
metaphors but I think it'd be helpful if
I said a little bit about the stages of
spiritual development that James Fowler
unpacked and other people may because at
this point so exactly what you're
talking about so when we begin our
spiritual journey we tend to inherit the
beliefs that we've been given from
culture or family etc and that's where
most people are they've just inherited
beliefs and they haven't really
reflected on them they haven't changed
them or adjust them they just are doing
what they inherited as people begin to
mature they move out of a just inherited
form of spirituality - one that's
actually self reflexive meaning they
take a moment and they pause and they
think about it and they say well is this
really what I believe or is this just
what I inherited usually during that
fray in that phase one of two things
happens either one people reject the
spirituality altogether they've
inherited because they rebel against it
now that they realize they've inherited
something they didn't do consciously or
they just take a bit more critical view
of it but still potentially embrace it
or I guess there's a third option people
begin to explore other options so as you
move into that third level where you
start to explore all their options it's
what you describe where spirituality
becomes pluralistic where you start to
say well there's something similar in
this tradition and similar in this
tradition you begin to look across
multiple different traditions seeing
similarities
and I think that's awesome super helpful
super good yeah and at the same time
there are fundamental differences across
different traditions and faiths and it's
not necessarily the case that all pasts
actually lead to the same end or the
same result that's something that many
people say from less informed
perspective because it sounds really
nice and the pluralistic orientation is
that all paths do lead to the same place
but as actually are quite different and
actually lead to different types of
realizations now that doesn't mean that
that's a bad thing because what we found
through research and my mentor Dan Brown
at Harvard it was one of the pioneers of
this is that even if the results of the
past tend to be a little bit different
based on the bias and perspectives of
the traditions there is some deep
structure to a spiritual path that
actually is similar across traditions so
then we need to make a distinction
between the deep structure of spiritual
awakening and the surface features how
it actually presents and the
realizations that unfold but I don't to
get ahead of myself
is as we look at that pluralistic view
what then starts to happen is that we
say oh there are enough similarities
where I can take a path extremely deep
and I can supplement and complement with
the different aspects of the tradition
that aren't supported as strongly within
my tradition so we're not just looking
at a buffet but we're looking at a path
where we can go really deep in one and
supplement and I think that actually is
an extremely helpful orientation because
it's not saying that we have to be
exclusive we can actually be quite
inclusive of other paths but it's to say
that I'm willing to commit and go all
the way in one path and supplement it
across different paths in different
traditions so I find that really useful
that's James Fowler's work and I've
written many books that incorporate
those particular worldviews okay so as
we endeavor into consciousness we have
initially these stages of development
where culture our family act as primary
forces on what we think spiritually then
there's a reflective process where we
think of may be happening later in our
lives for me this is a very like 20s
thing that happens
actually we start to gain that capacity
between nine and twelve that capacity
for that type of reflective thinking so
some people reflecting on their own
experience listening to this may find
that like even in their early teens they
started to reject the inherited
spiritual systems that they received so
yeah for other people it's older but we
can have a happen at many different
times in life because it's important to
remember Island we have different lines
of development meaning that we have a
spiritual aina development we have moral
lines of development cognitive lines of
development these things all can develop
independently and so some people
spiritual development might not be as
evolved as their cognitive development
or might not be as evolved as their
moral development or their ego
development so we have to make sure
we're looking at this and sort of a
broad and more sophisticated way some
people might do that in their 20s other
people or earlier some people their 60s
yeah this is probably very commonly
expelled and experienced in our society
with how we talk about something like
that someone with really high IQ and
someone of really high like social
emotional intelligence EQ and so this is
a very common way of like now starting
to see our world and so we talk a lot
about being able to like mix like a like
polymath II with with with empathy or EQ
and when you can like really mix those
two together you can achieve great
things but you know IQ can also be very
deep depth in a specific field but just
now when you say that many of us now to
have an opportunity to kind of reflect
and be like well where am I on a on my
spiritual path versus my cognitive path
where is my emotional path my your
physical path there's well you know all
these different well being social path
there's all these different like well
beings or past that can then we can see
what stages of development were at in
them and to continue on that last point
just a little bit more when you have the
the influences of the early stages of
development when you start reflecting
and seeing you know 9 to 12 the teens
the 20s when you have this time to like
be like you said you may be you may find
something that is
but getting you into the drop merging
with the ocean your your Rica munion
with the one and as you do that process
there is something that's getting you
down in the well most for finding water
and complementing other paths along the
way to continue and I think you point to
something really important here which is
that when people say all paths lead to
the same place that there may be similar
properties of the paths that are maybe
around transcendence or around some sort
of a communion with something that is
transcendent but you also said that they
don't point to the same place and so
there are different places that point
towards yeah could I give you example I
would love that
yeah him so at some point it may be
useful to make a distinction between
what Wilbur would call stages of
development or structures of development
and states of spiritual realization
so at some point you may want to talk
about that because I was a bit of a
conflation and how I heard you repeat
things back so then let's do that now
because I want to learn on that okay and
and and I think there's also really use
a lot of usefulness and articulating
sort of some of the things you just
pointed to okay so when we talk about
something like stages of cognitive
development or stages of moral
development or stages of spiritual
development we're talking about
structures of mind and these develop in
a predictable unfold of unfolding
pattern throughout the course of
someone's life but it's important to
realize that these structures of how we
orient towards spirituality don't aren't
actually the same thing as these sort of
stages of realization or stages of
spiritual awakening one could be at a
fundamentalist or more what we call the
an orientation that thinks at their
particular tradition the one they've
inherited is the only right tradition
without reflecting on it and they can
still have authentic spiritual
realization so you have to think about
two different vectors one
vector horizontal and when horse also on
one vertical so you can be anywhere on
that vertical spectrum of development
but you can still wake up across that
horizontal spectrum so it's one of the
contributions of Wilbur's work and some
of the work that I've tried to continue
out is to show that spiritual awakening
and spiritual development through these
structures is actually our union our
unique and the reason that's so vital is
because someone could be again a
fundamentalist the meaning that they're
not very high and their spiritual
intelligence but still have authentic
spiritual realization or spiritual
experiences someone could also be
extremely high in their spiritual
realize their spiritual intelligence but
maybe haven't had very many spiritual
insights or aren't very spiritually
awake so we need both of these one of
the simplest ways that I describe this
is that we need to be both woke mean
that through our spiritual development
we understand the plurality of existence
we understand how systems interact with
each other we understand social
inequalities etc and we need to be awake
we need to be both woke and awake woke
meaning that we have a capacity to
understand the complexity of our current
systems and awake meaning that we've
come to know ourselves as this unbounded
wholeness so you can be awoke and not
wake you can be woke up but not awake
and wake but not woke we need both of
those okay okay
this is helping so on a woke miss is the
realization of pluralism on paths and
then awakeness is the experiential
wisdom of timeless unbounded whole
that's a good way to articulate it yeah
it's a bit more complex than that but I
think for the simple purposes of art
what we're doing it's a great way to
understand that okay interesting
interesting
I can I can totally now see where we may
accidentally slip into only being one of
those two and many people are yeah yeah
okay interesting so many people can
understand the priority of big spiritual
traditions or understand the ways in
which social context influence sort of
inequality and things like this on sort
of four different forms of inequity or
social injustice that's a very important
definition of how we need to become more
woke or more
developed with our spiritual
intelligence and our sort of broad
intelligences in general but those
people aren't necessarily awake to the
fact that they are unbounded Honus with
no separation from everyone and
everything and vice versa is also true
we know many many spiritual teachers who
have authentic awakening but don't quite
understand the dimensions of plurality
that we're speaking about both of those
codes us we need both excellent thank
you for helping me with that that's
crucial for my understanding I'm
hopefully for others as well and now
let's do the examples so you were
speaking a bit about the differences
between how paths may unfold I want to
give you one example one of the
teachings that I learned from from Ken
Wilber early in my 20s was something
called
the three phases of God I want to unpack
that a little bit so in our basic
language structure we have the
orientations using first person second
person and third person language first
person means I or following subjectivity
second person meaning thou or an i thou
and third person meaning in it so
different spiritual systems have
developed with biases towards these
various perspectives so for example a
buddhist tradition and the way that
we've inherited in the west it's a
little bit different in its native
context focuses on a first-person
perspective you trace your own awareness
and you trace that subjectivity all the
way back to its source which can be this
type of unbounded open awareness the
Christian tradition and the Jewish
tradition and the Islamic tradition tend
to take a second person relationship
towards ultimate reality meaning there's
an i thou relationship forms of prayer
are often very common in these
traditions where there's a relationship
with reality it's not about tracing your
own first-person awareness back to its
source it's about being in such close
devotion and relationship with the
divine you actually find yourself
merging ultimately there's a
third-person perspective and I like to
use Neil deGrasse Tyson as one of the
examples of this like someone who's so
fascinated with the cosmos yeah he's in
awe constantly because of how the cosmos
is such a miracle and if we take that
orientation look at the Carl Sagan
approach or the gas-station approach we
can actually feel the excitement in the
awe and the surrender that's released
than our being but there's no
relationship and there
not a first-person subjectivity that
you're tracing back what you're doing is
that you're relating to ultimate reality
is a great it this amazing amazing
unfolding but it's objectified now all
those are very different perspectives
and they lead to very different types of
realization but underneath that sort of
surface feature the deep structure is
similar that it leads towards some sort
of opening or some sort of liberation
some sort of freedom yeah and I think
that's what's important that sometimes
the perennial lists who want to say
everything leads to the same thing they
sometimes miss that distinction that
there are different perspectives what
Dan Brown calls biasing perspectives
that lead towards different types of
realization but the fundamental
underlying structure there's something
that there's there's a liberation that
can unfold is actually the same across
traditions whoa okay I feel like I used
a transcendence and then you use
liberation yes you use either one okay
cool interesting often a transcendence
of the separate self or TransAm yeah
individual right yes yes yes yeah
remember but this is something that's so
important to view for the readers
listeners to understand transcendence is
always a transcendence include when
sometimes happens in people who are just
being oriented toward spirituality is
they start to identify with
transcendence and they reject or deny
their sense of relative self and it's
really really important that we're
healthy relative self even as we
transcend that self into a larger
ultimate reality so spiritual
realization is a process of transcending
and including including the relative
self but also transcending it to
establish your identity as something
much whole or wider larger this reminds
me of what Jack Engler says where Jaclyn
guru says you have to be somebody before
you can be nobody all right so it's
really important to be somebody and then
you can step into the fact that you're
nobody but that nobody then lives
through this relative sense of somebody
yeah and the two aren't separate the two
are actually the part of an integrated
whole and there's many people in the
spiritual community who I've interacted
with and who I've seen who make this air
that they transcend and don't include so
they're spaced out rather than spacious
or they're disconnected spiritually
bypassing all of the relative experience
rather than fully integrated and feeling
help
painful it is to be a human being we
want to do both of those we want to feel
and be totally human and we want to
understand fully through our direct
experience that we're all so much more
than that
yeah as though at the earliest parts of
the adventure of consciousness there are
feelings of self then there is the
exploration of all of the paths and the
feelings of transcending self and then
there's the process of including which
which is highly around us having a wise
moment to moment experience with the
self the unbounded timeless wholeness
also the in the in this previous bit
where you're where you're where you're
taking us there's this there's this
layer of liberation that can be
reached through myriad processes and
we've been talking so much on the
program about the beauty of the merging
of science and spirituality in a in a
harmony towards the architecting of a
more prosperous world and in a sense
that is this
I really appreciated your breakdown
because I've sampled now those three
that you've list that you listed where
we take the perspective of the Buddhist
awareness going to source through our
awareness through the vehicle itself the
I've al relationship with the divine and
then the being just profoundly awakened
to divinity through understanding how a
cell works or how quantum mechanics
works or orbital dynamics or what ever
aspect I think for me having felt these
different structures has been paramount
in my ability to be open and loving and
compassionate to up other people on
their journeys in the way that they are
finding their processes
yeah and how you are anything now
between those perspectives which one is
the most resonant for you or maybe it's
a combination of all of them
yes a
drop merging with the ocean seems to be
the most which is likely the the first
the Buddhists through the through the I
it seems to be the most common through
the high to source um but like whenever
my worldview becomes I get a Eureka
moment in my worldviews a lot of times
from the drop merging with ocean but
also from the me crying at what are some
of these like source codes within
creation within source that have made
this reality and unpacking those with
the scientific method you see a lot of
beauty in that process and so I'm crying
a lot from that as well and so that like
yeah what about you that's beautiful
I find that these all all these
perspectives aren't mutually exclusive
like you're saying and we can take that
subjective first-person view all the way
to its end back to source and this sort
of broad open lucid unbounded awareness
is here that's not separate from
anything and at the same time we can be
in a radical devotion from this relative
self towards a divine or towards the
beauty and fascination of the amazing
way that the universe unfolds and I find
that these perspectives and rich each
other yeah and as we develop along the
path that it's actually there's a
fullness that comes from taking all
three perspectives simultaneously many
people in my experience are impoverished
because they've cut out one of these
perspectives particularly people in
Western culture who were raised in an
inherited way they inherited
of a judeo-christian orientation and so
very naturally as they began to question
that they often reject that particular
view and they lean toward something like
science or something like Buddhism so
either a third person or first person
orientation and it's been my experience
at least in my own life and the people
that I've worked with is that when we
include that second person perspective
there's an incredible richness that
comes with that it allows us to actually
being a loving universe and in
relationship with a loving universe not
just a magical universe that were in awe
about and not just a universe that is no
separate not separate from our own
awareness but in relationship with the
universe in a way that's incredibly
nurturing and so I I really encourage
people to explore these particularly if
they've had some sort of break or
rejection where they've moved into more
of this atheistic view because they are
scientific or rational you know these
all can coexist it's really rich yes it
seems as though that may be one of the
most paramount things to happen around
our world is for the hyper-rational
technology builders scientists to
experience some of these spiritual paths
that may give them a deeper ethical
moral or philosophical grounding that
will help prevent issues that may come
from developing said science and
technologies into the world and ensure
that they are built for maximizing
prosperity and abundance and flourishing
that seems to be something especially
close to the hearts of areas that have
such great influence like Hollywood and
Silicon Valley to to have these
experiences that help with what we're
actually architecting absolutely yeah I
mean we we have to have right motivation
we have to ever have motivation to
create the world that is gonna benefit
everyone
and sometimes these experiences that
we're talking about can help encourage
people to have good motivation because
they start to understand the
magnificence of reality and that they
can be participants in that reality and
contributors to it not just people who
are consuming and taking for their own
sort of selfish desires and needs I
think it's extremely important what
you're saying we're speaking about the
word reciprocity who has been crucial
pillar in my realization of that every
breath of air every sip of water every
bite of food every every shower every
show using this equipment every
beautiful moments that I get with other
people in their eyes that having deep
reciprocity towards our planet that
sustains us towards each other how do
you keep that in mind when you're
breathing for example how do you keep
that reciprocity in mind what do you do
a moment-to-moment kind of orientation
do you have be useful for people to hear
I appreciate the amount of tennis balls
that you hit back my way to get 600
shows you know questions yeah whenever
that does happen there's really good
formulations on mine that helped a lot
and in answer to this one
I've passed a lot of feeling now on what
has been a
a hydrological cycle or an an air cycle
that has been here since billions of
years prior to me and that I am still
today a recipient of phytoplankton and
trees that are providing me with the
oxygen that I breathe and that the same
water that I drink today is what
dinosaurs drank and that I'm when I tie
myself in like that and when I even sit
here and breathe that we can melt into
those breaths the sip of water we can
melt into the sip of water it's just
it's a I keep hearing this word so much
practice about practice and practice
that moment-to-moment timeless unbounded
wholeness and then you become that but
like it's practice and so that's
probably my feeling is that I'm I'm a
work in progress towards that mmm-hmm
and that's what how about you I love
those examples even I think they're
fantastic it's a way that you're
bringing it into your everyday life
moment by moment if you can remember to
do it for me the key to practice to you
know keep building on this term is to
remember to practice I mean many of us
know what to do we just forget it's one
of the basic big key to practice is to
remember to practice it's true when
you're one of the fundamental poisons
within the tibetan world that i've been
immersed in is ignorance is that we
forget I diluted and we forget and for
me this is what mentors are all about my
main mentor Dan Brown in the world of
Tibetan Buddhism and meditation one of
the first questions I asked him I said
Dan you know I've had some of these
experiences of being so this open
unbounded awareness is it possible like
to have that all the time
he said to me that's the whole point
whole point is to actually have that
moment by moment to not forget yes
because the tendency is to forget over
and over again and there's all kinds of
ways that we can build out structures
and I like to support that but one of
the most basic ways to start building it
is through a meditation practice and if
you think about a meditation practice
you can think of it from sort of the
neuroscientific lens you can think of it
through a peak performance lens we were
developing concentration you're really
making your mind fit for flow States you
can use all the language I think more
for me and more profound in the deeper
way to say you're actually gonna take
time to remember you're gonna take time
to not forget because so much of our
life is based on forgetting what we know
intuitively that part of our own
awareness you know it said many of us
have tasted awakening many times before
where we've just forgotten so take time
to remember this root of religion this
root meaning like to rejoin joy to
remember all of us are just so forgetful
and so for me practice is simply about
remembering and developing the
structures in our life and the
relationships in our life that help us
remember moments a moment then if we
remember we're in a much better position
to help others and to create the world
that we want to create if we forget and
we're acting from all of our unconscious
motivations then we're gonna create more
of the world that we've seen so far so
we have to remind each other and remind
ourselves it's true Sangha Sangha as the
word and the Buddhist community means
means a group of practitioners who are
committed to each other's realization
and practice and Sangha we're here to
remind each other hey don't forget my
wife tugs on our ear and everywhere in
public and cheese sees that I've totally
forgotten all he just goes hey wow she
reminds me she helps me remember what a
cool
sign and we can do it for each other and
yeah so during the interview oh oh a
mighty little tuggers yeah for those
that are open to taking a similar you're
tug for remembering please that's a
really fun one for those also that are
open to to that this is maybe a good
question to ask is what for Sango we
surround ourselves usually with people
that are committed to the practice of
remembering on a moment-to-moment basis
yet we usually as the great quote goes
if you think you are enlightened spend a
month with your family what do we do
about our you know our parents that we
love so dearly yet that don't
necessarily want to play though yeah
maybe there's something you know maybe
there's folks being born at least in the
last generation or actually had parents
who did remember yes we're in good shape
you know this is how the evolution of
spiritual teachings actually really take
root is that you do have parents
remember but many of us didn't have
parents who remember so I think one of
the best ways is to first understand
that it's understandable that we forget
in the presence of family in the
presence of teachers because presence of
parents because our relative sense of
self was formed in the presence and the
cauldron of our family structure and our
relative sense of self being pulled back
into that sort of smaller self is often
what happens when Oren family totally
understandable
wow that's how it was formed we can have
compassion for ourselves but as we
deepen our practice and we can be hyper
aware and vigilant as we go into those
situations then it's natural that we
remember more and more in those
situations and no longer has that kind
of pull and then we naturally butterfly
effect our timeless unbounded wholeness
to our but often it doesn't show up as a
transmission of that time was boundless
awareness it shows up as a transmission
of kind
sir yes something else is beneficial I
think there might be people who are
fortunate enough to have parents who are
open to that my parents opposed to
express interest in their own ways and
that type of thing my father sat on
retreat with Dan Brown did what social
thing Wow whoa that is so neat yeah and
we've had friends that have said that
they've had yeah a really strong
butterfly effects where their parents
have then there's been catalyzation of
some sort of inquiry from them about the
what's this bliss state that you're
meant the best thing to do is be an
example yeah my gag I'm quoting Dan so
much is because I've learned so much
from him and he's had such a profound
impact I mean he often says better to be
a Buddha than a Buddhist so it's better
to actually be a living example of
what's possible rather than try to you
know convince people through your words
or language its we have to really embody
it we know we know deep practice and
remembrance through conduct and how we
show up in the world so showing up and
being the teachings is the best thing we
can possibly do yeah that's it I love
that yeah okay another question that is
of great inquiry to to me right now
we've been playing with a lot is is this
reality a a perfect harmonization or
flux of good and evil and Tibetan
teachings there's a
perspective or deity called
Samantabhadra and this perspective is
that what a means or sometimes how its
translated is everything good and from
that particular perspective the idea
that there's something wrong or there's
something evil that you're in harmony
with is it's sort of a moot question so
from that perspective everything is good
everything's here to show us our way
back onto the path that reality itself
is constantly trying everything I can to
to reveal itself to itself and if we
take that perspective then everything is
a gift along the path everything is a
gesture of compassion to show us our way
home so from that perspective thing I
don't think that we're in some sort of
dualistic battle between good and evil
and there's a perfect harmony in these
kind of things I think everything from
the right view is a orientation to bring
us back more deeply and more fully to
our own true nature to our own
realization that perspective resonates
with me much more and it tends to be a
very effective way to live and to
practice Wow so could it be then that
this is a perfect pressure cooker
reality a perfect pressure cooker for
the spiritual path yeah the reality is
here for the benefit of its own
realization through all of us as you
know we experience more and more of its
unfolding but that is the process that's
unfolding is that we're in the pressure
cooker of realization and that if we
actually allow ourselves to align as
fully as we possibly can with that
intention that motivation not just to
awaken for our own benefit but to waken
so that we can participate in the
fullness of this chlorophyll experience
and for the benefit of others then you
know it's a pretty magical universe to
live in it's hard to live in that
perspective all the time but that's what
remembering is all about and when we're
not in that perspective it's okay we
forget from time to time and we suffer
deeply as a result
and have my dear friend of mine often
says you know pain is inevitable and
suffering is optional alright so the
ways in which were hurt and that reality
is actually deeply traumatic moments a
moment doesn't go away even as we
develop deeper on the path but our
perspectives change and there is a point
where we no longer are suffering when
pain arises but what it actually allows
us to feel more fully as we feel
experience more fully our heart opens to
feel others experience more fully and
becomes this amazing virtuous cycle of
feeling and orienting towards a
tenderness of what it's like to be human
yeah well we're also simultaneously
recognizing they were in the pressure
cooker of reality revealing itself to
itself which is also awesome yes yes now
how does one being born in Columbus Ohio
and then pursuing Cornell and pursuing
Harvard studies of religion getting
involved with 10 for 15 years Dan for 12
years
how have you been on the the process of
navigating to identify and then you
yourself how do you you know parse for
the the things that are working for you
you know when I when I was in my early
20s I had spent time living in Paris
after Cornell I'd moved to India to be a
monk I'd lived this sort of very
dualistic lifestyle eventually settled
in Denver Colorado where I met Ken
Wilber and I'd written a letter and I
said I really want to come work with you
I've done all these different things but
I want to find a middle way and his
interval Institute at the time was
something it really resonated with me as
I found my way deeper into relationship
with Ken what I found in him was a
theoretical model of how all these
pieces that seemed to be separate for me
could all fit together into a
comprehensive whole this what he's
called interval theory sort of an
integrated worldview it was so helpful
for me because up until that point at
all these different areas of
interest but I didn't quite see how the
pieces of the puzzle fit together
what integral theory does is it allows
you to put all the pieces on the table
across all different cultures and
throughout time and different different
epochs of time Wow and we can then say
oh there are these patterns that emerge
yeah this is what it means to be human
this is what we've inherited through
history this is what we've been heritage
as a great human civilization how to
build a map and let's build actual
practices that act it so that's what I
learned from Ken on one side but I also
learned from kindless that Ken in the
way he showed up his loving presence and
the way that he was like unbroken Lea
caring when I'd interact with him it
showed me an example of what it means to
love so I often say from Ken I learned
two things one is I learned how
everything fit together which was really
useful but I also learned how to love
yeah I didn't know how to love in time
at someone like him so ken was what sort
of brought me on to a deeper like
practice-based path meaning that like
right now in the moment this matters on
how I'm relating to you matters a few
years later I met Dan Brown and Dan was
really who like put their rocket fuel in
my personal practice because the Tibetan
teachings that he's trained in for 40
years and in his clinical practice that
he's had at Harvard for also around 3540
years it was like I had stumbled upon
this goldmine of wealth and information
both on the clinical side and the
tibetan side and I often say Tibet is
like the Silicon Valley of the mind
so Tibetan culture is isolated on this
plateau for hundreds and hundreds of
years and it just became this incubator
for transformative practice because the
invaders couldn't get in if just it was
amazing so we have all these practices
when China came into Tibet and the the
reorientation happened the Tibetans all
became refugees in that Dharma spread
throughout the world isn't this amazing
gift
and so from damn what I learned was like
wow people have actually come to
understand what are the practices step
by step that we can do to take somebody
from ordinary everyday suffering into a
level of practice and realization where
they actually experience themselves as
this this this drop merging with the
ocean they experience themselves as the
ocean
and how do we stabilize that moment a
moment how do we take that into dreaming
how do we take that into deep sleep how
do we allow ourselves to unfold on a
path where all of the time or
remembering and the Tibetans have
figured this stuff out we don't have to
reinvent the wheel it's amazing what's
built into this tradition that I've been
able to learn from dan and that I'm
sharing with others so I found my way
onto the path somewhat through accident
but also through just incredible
good fortune you know good fortune that
I've met people I can and through Ken
and Dan this might have been the first
time that I heard that the traumas of
Tibet that Dharma is spreading around
the world are actually being viewed as
one of the greatest treasures of being
spread it's I'm not sure that's a
popular view it's the first time yeah
I'm here I don't think yeah actually one
of the most common themes of the
different guests that we have on the
program is that they've seen their
greatest traumas as their greatest
treasures it's a very common theme so we
can look at globally great traumas there
are great treasures exactly which is
very hard to also think about given the
great deal of like trauma from like a
transatlantic slave trade to see
treasures from like a Scramble for
Africa or from all the different and
genocides that have happened across
planet like there's it's really hard but
it's also really important to heal on a
both an individual level seeing
treasures and also on a collective level
from these bigger traumas seeing seeing
treasures that was very interesting what
you mentioned and also 10 in many ways
reminds me of what it feels like my next
chapter that source is channeling
through is meant to be
there's a lot that is coming into our
daily reality as unstructured data and
anyone worth their salt in the field of
deep learning will tell you that
structured data is extremely important
and that if you want to make models make
find patterns structuring data like this
reality being filled with so much what
feels like noise and signal at the same
time and being able to structure of the
different pockets of signal into a
cohesive map or cannon of all of the
different signals and what people can go
and and we remove the fog of war we
remove the veil and we give people
ability to see the signals experience
the signals find what works for them and
go find the water and you're very
fortunate because you've got to wit that
I would say are at the absolute
cutting-edge Ken and Dan and that's
really important for you pass it along
now you have a great responsibility to
continue passing this along and you do
you've now how many meditation retreats
have you colette / lead how many have
you have you done now with Dan or just
in general and with many retreats yeah I
mean one of the biggest gifts of
studying with him
has been in a princess ship model a
model where there is a learning-by-doing
where I'd sit with him on retreat he's
right next to me we're teaching together
he's obviously has the 40 years more
experience than me so I'm a baby when it
comes to this but he sits me in the seat
to actually start learning how to do it
I'll make a comment he'll whisper
something in my ear a little tweak or
correction I could do this type of
relational based practice and mentorship
that I've received is absolutely
incredible and I'd say the same thing
with with Ken and that can I now have a
course on insight timer for example we
we talk about the importance of we call
wake up grow up clean up show up which
we can talk about at some point in time
but this this whole idea of teaching
with somebody and president preserving
the wisdom that they've been able to
sort of come to yes is something I feel
so passionate about so for example Dan
for 40 years has taught with the Tibetan
side-by-side and has helped to preserve
these teachings in a way that makes them
living and alive in the West
not just through book form both through
like real life sitting next to each
other and sharing yeah and you know for
the past six years of training
Dan's giving me this opportunity to sit
with him and to train and to learn and
then to share that with the MIT students
so my hope with all of this is that
there's an ongoing preservation of
what's come in what we've all inherited
and for that it's just like nothing but
I'm unbelievably heartfelt gratitude
like you were saying like the water you
drink if you can take that orientation
the dinosaurs drink the same water like
as you drink it there's no other
experience you can have other than
gratitude like oh I'm so grateful you
can savor it yeah so there's an aspect
of my experience that just is so
grateful for everything that I've
received and how I can you know express
it and always what happens with
spiritual teachings that they have to
meet the current time and the different
dynamics that are present in the current
situation so in addition to preservation
there's always innovation
so it's this dance between preserving
the essence and innovating in the most
relevant and potent way for this
particular moment in time
so preservation innovation and it's that
dialectical tension between those two
sometimes people lean too far on the
innovation side and when they lean too
far on the innovation side they forget
the preservation sometimes you believe
too far in the preservation side and
they aren't present
the current context of what's most
helpful now yes in these circumstances
and so of course we need both of those
and you know I like other people in my
generation or in these positions where
we're trying to hold that balance and
you know imperfectly as we're doing it
like there's a lot of us were very
earnest and trying to do it well like
Tibetan Buddhism meeting tik-tok yeah
what does that look like I don't know
what that looks like I'm sure we'll find
out in some ways yeah yeah but there's
also this danger in the innovation side
that like we dilute things and so it's
always about preserving the essence in
the way that doesn't dilute anything and
so you know can we do something I take
back the one diluted I don't know yeah
yeah that's well said there have been a
couple of those very short videos of
that I've seen that are trying to
communicate some sort of timeless
spiritual wisdom in one of the short to
katalk videos and it I think it works
more for those that are already
somewhere along the path because it kind
of causes them to like reflect for that
like little 15 second period but the one
of the things is that then the scroll
goes to just the next video which is
usually something around like
entertainment which can sometimes take
us out of the Dead State so I'm not even
sure how those things harmonize a 15
second like attention video generation
harmonizing with the what requires a
very very serious focused practice of
uncovering the nature of reality through
awareness and through breath to source
that's uh that's there's it seems to be
lots of incompatibilities with the 15
and video scrolling app and so that's
just something that to consider but also
to try and find I really okay you let's
let's hit let's is from where you
initially started it which is that you
are now responsible for the preservation
and innovation simultaneously of what
you've been gifted and likewise I am as
well with what we've been gifted on the
program the preservation and innovation
of all these different things that we've
been taught and so there's something
here that has now come up over and over
and over again which is that we're going
through an ethnographic condensation
where you have 7,000 languages currently
spoken that are half are not being
taught to children so it's already
dropping to 3,500 and there's just a
greater and greater push for people to
solely be learning English or learning
Mandarin or etc and so we have also a
responsibility to preserve culture
around the planet because there's
pockets of great timeless spiritual
wisdom that occur in many of the First
Nations in Canada or in the Native
Americans in the US or in the the
plethora of indigenous cultures in in in
in Latin America so in Africa there's
just there's so many pockets that exist
like that and that basically indigeneity
has been like this is such a common
thing on the program
curious to hear how you feel about it
99.9% of human time has been in
indigeneity and then agrarian society
10,000 years and then especially
enlightenment and Industrial Revolution
500 and so - and that's only 0.1% of
time of being human and so to think that
all of our wisdom is concentrated in
modernity is hubristic it's myopic and
it needs a humility check mm-hmm not
only in sort of the modern era but also
in sort of mostly the the Western modern
era I mean there's a I used to always
give this teaching and it's very
imperfect but it's sometimes useful so
as a sort of a teaching - a pedagogical
tool is that what I really aspire to is
a deep integration of north south east
and west and let me just say a bit about
sort of what I see as some of the gifts
of these different broad swaths and it's
imperfect because none of these
communities are you know homogeneous and
they're not monolithic and there's so
much diversity within them but just for
the sake of like I'm robbery at the
orientation so what the Western world
has really offered us an incredible a
few incredible - of many incredible
tools but this idea of sort of a
rational scientific lens that allows us
to actually have a hypothesis to test it
out to check the results that are
reliable and repeatable this is really
this is cool and this this capacity to
understand some of the broader unfolding
in sort of a process-oriented or an
evolutionary context so you just laid
out sort of some of the epics of
humanity from sort of early indigenous
to agrarian to industrial - maybe
informations maybe something more
integrative etc so that's really
valuable to sort of see things in these
broad strokes
I think that's useful it's one of the
gifts of the Western mind at the same
time one of some of the the gifts that
come from say like the Tibetan culture
or some of these more Eastern embeded
called
so that the if we actually examine our
own subjective experience and we
actually knows notice that moments a
moment there is an awareness even though
things seem to be unfolding in this
evolutionary way there's an aspect of
our experience that's always here it's
interesting now it's a new moment but
like there's an aspect of experience
it's still right now it's aspect of our
experience it's thorne I was here beep
when I we were a child it's here now
it's now a few seconds later than I
first said it but there's this aspect of
experience that's here now you start to
understand there's an aspect of our own
experience or awareness that's beyond
the coming and going of time if we take
that even further than we start to
explore we begin to realize wow that
awareness isn't separate it actually is
huge it's beyond our physical body it's
unbounded it's timeless it's unbounded
it's whole when we integrate these two
perspectives we get this timeless
unbounded awareness that's also you know
seeing itself show up and evolving
within time that's very cool east and
west integration from the north and the
south what I find is there's these these
rich traditions these rich indigenous
traditions that actually are holding a
wisdom around how we actually come into
a deeper harmony with the natural world
yeah a deeper harmony with the natural
world through you know the way that we
eat food the way that we build community
the way that we interact with each other
and also because of that deep harmony
with the natural world there's an
incredible understanding around
medicines and healing but also around
the ways in which plants and entheogens
can actually transform the way we
experience reality yes so there's this
amazing capacity for these indigenous
cultures and tribes to teach us about
how we be in relationship with each
other how we're in relationship with the
earth and how we're in relationship with
these amazing kingdoms of plants and
animals and you know minerals yeah and
so if there's something about this trans
Kingdom harmony that comes from the
north and the south and we combine that
view with this evolutionary view and
this undoubted wholeness view we get a
bit more sort of sophisticated
orientation to how we might live both in
right relationship but also with right
realization and also in sort of the
right unfolding of evolutionary time in
process and to me that's a much fuller
realization and that's these are some of
the things that I've learned through my
study with robear's that these
perspectives can all fit together and
they're all holding a piece of the
puzzle
when I think that what pieces I love he
says no one is smart enough to be a
hundred percent wrong right so what that
means is that everybody is holding some
piece of a truth and they're also
partial so everything is true but
partial so when we begin to look at the
world with a hermeneutic of generosity
we interpret the world with a generous
spirit we begin to say oh well there
must be some truth in that even if
there's a lot of it that might be
partial there's something true there we
begin to look at the world with this
generous spirit we see oh everything
actually has something to offer
something to contribute and that to me
is the gift of an integral theory is
that we begin to see a much more robust
and rich and pluralistic experience of
reality that also is a unfolding
throughout time in a really incredible
way that can benefit all of us and the
planet and beyond to me that's super
exciting so north south east west this
is the the global wisdom tradition
that's unfolding is an integration of
all these streams into one great human
tradition yes Wow I really like that
yeah the north south east of us what's
your experience with some of these
indigenous cultures and ways in which we
can learn from our you know the Kogi and
the Andes colors as though you know
older brothers of humanity yeah there's
probably some truth to that yeah oh
what's your relationship with some of
these these different groups of people
and whether we look at cultural systems
or just your own experience with some of
these things I really liked the way that
you phrase framed it I think that's a
really strong analogy that seems like
it's actually very much so uh compass
they're just they're they're so integral
to one another into this this new world
that we're all part of the evolutionary
process of yeah my relationships with
that north south east and west are as
you described as we've been describing
throughout that
mmm I love the I love the paths in those
and that my sampling of the paths of
those have been instrumental to my own
spiritual path but also my hopefully
ability to help empathize with people
that are on their paths sampling their
processes of awakening relating with
them being uh getting into dialectic
with them about them and then also on
them on the program as well trying to
take these great analogies and hopefully
have them be a centerpiece of of
discourse in in society because this
spiritual path is the path and it is
being the fundamental layer in our
social fabric would be transformative
and you mentioned this throughout and I
think it's so important to point it out
we talked about this so much that having
mmm
sitting there with like Dan Brown or Ken
Wilber in having a a mentor a one-on-one
mentorship which has so many studies
through Bloom to Sigma and all these
other studies showing that you perform
just exceptionally as an outlier beyond
an average when you have one-on-one
mentorship and so in this case I and
other viewers get one-on-one mentorship
from all the guests that come onto the
program you have the one-on-one
mentorship of Dan and Ken in their
states of communicating what they hope
to inspire other people to awaken with
and
it's a very common theme for people that
come on the program as well to say
things like if you want to get involved
in and in a field or an industry or on
the spiritual path what better way than
to tell the than to reach out to the
people that are at the cutting edge of
those fields industries paths and say
hey I would like to get involved and I'm
willing to work for free and no one's
gonna do a better job than me I'm
dedicated to succeeding for you for the
edge that you're pushing and learning
from you directly as a mentor one-on-one
and that young person is gonna set
themselves drastically apart from their
peers because they're willing to go into
the edge for one-on-one mentorship for
free and do work that is for on behalf
of that edge pushing that is hopefully a
really good great quality and maybe even
leads them to an actual paid position
within that within that afterward yeah
comment on that please yeah you know I
think it's really important here to
mention privilege you know I hear like
the the I have so much I need to become
so much more woke and I recognize that
like I'm not very welcome to and I want
to say that I just recognized that the
position and the articulation that was
just outlined it comes from extreme
privilege perspective even the idea of
working for free and all these things
it's not necessary it's not I want to
just be really good that this mentorship
relationship isn't necessary to enter in
and start the surgery of your own
transformation and you're on the
spiritual path one of the groups that I
I'm so excited about working with this
called credible mind calm and credible
mind has assimilated all these different
practices for mental health and
spiritual growth and we've taken a whole
panel of experts and given all these
resources readings and we have user
readings and it basically is like to the
substitute mentor because one of the
things that I got from Dan McCann as I
said oh try this read this book check
this
but if we look at the the swath of
spiritual text today and text about
mental health and well-being there is
information overload where were content
obese with this type of information this
maybe we were speaking with like
unstructured information yeah there's so
much of it and so what we try to do with
quite a mind to say okay let's start
sorting through some of these things
let's start positioning things with
we're saying oh this is actually expert
rated that says five stars written you
know rated by experts all the best
mentors so I just want to say that that
privilege perspective is now being
supplemented with a totally free
resource of people to say here are the
best things that help you along your
spiritual path
here's the things that are
evidence-based here the things that
really work for your mental health and
for your flourishing and life them so I
just wanted to mention that because this
the sort of democratization of some of
this information is so vital that it's
not just call this act into communities
of privilege and to the elite so there
is something available credible mind
calm as one and there's many many others
credible credible mind credible mind
credible mind calm awesome all also that
link will put in the bio as well for
people credible mind calm the
democratization of awakening is
incredible and it is also different to
read or watch about it than it is to
have a one-on-one witness the dust and
hmm that mmm-hmm hope that helps me on
the path so there's a a friend of mine
named Bruce Lyon and he once told me a
metaphor that I think is useful in this
context and I hear a lot today about
people talking about the democratization
of enlightenment some accusation of
spiritual awakening and they say the age
of the Guru or the spiritual teacher
said of over and we now have access to
all this information so when I said
before still still stands you can enter
onto the spiritual path and you can so
you can develop a huge robust set of
practices and teachings that are really
really helpful and that is true and that
remains true at the same time it's
really important at some point if you
can to find someone who's actually taken
a few steps further than you it doesn't
have to be the people at the cutting
edge
the best and the brightest but someone
is just a little bit further along from
the new so you can have a direct
relationship so I want to share with you
a metaphor Bruce said to me you know
we're moving from an era in which we
have isolated Suns with planets
revolving around them this is like the
solar model of the spiritual teacher and
the students who are the planets oh so
it's like the orbit of the Sun is the
people who are sort of finding
themselves in the orbit of the teacher
moving from that type of model to more
of a galactic model and in a galactic
model we start to actually realize
ourselves as Suns and we look around we
say oh there's another Sun there's a Sun
there all these illumine beings who
start to recognize and notice each other
but those Suns are axes centered around
this amazing event horizon of a black
hole yeah and that black hole nobody's
in the center of that it's actually an
infinite well of potential so we can
actually see ourselves in different
constellations as Suns and we can stand
around that event horizon of a black
hole of that infinite potential emerging
between us and through us that's a
really cool model but the reason I like
that model isn't just for the amazing
metaphor of the black hole but it's
because that's a transcendence include
model even those sons who are standing
in formation together around the black
hole may still have planets in their
orbit because there is a point in time
in a Souls evolution or individuals
development where they actually need the
nourishment of a Sun in order to
actually light up themselves like we as
Earth need the nourishment of the Sun
it's really vital to our existence into
our survival and so we can stand in that
light and we can actually be nourished
by the light until we ourselves become a
Sun so I use that model because it's a
transcendence include model the age of
the spiritual teacher the age of the Sun
with planets isn't over it's just been
transcended into a much larger
collective understanding that we can
stand as suns in orbit around a black
hole those Suns may still have their own
planets that they're lighting up to
become sons sons
yes yeah we both yes and that there may
be sons that burn brighter and that
weekend that's right also learn from
which is kind of like that where you
were saying earlier about finding
someone that's a little bit more mm-hmm
exactly and that we begin to understand
that you know the
Galaxy isn't flat but it's actually
three-dimensional so there are some Suns
that are more developed in different
areas than others and so those Suns
continue to learn from each other and to
evolve as they stand in that orbit
together so absolutely
I want to touch on the
continued preservation in innovation of
what the spiritual paths are bringing to
light that we are also working with the
combating of the ethnographic
condensation to aim to preserve how does
Brite Alliance do such work great thank
you so red Alliance comes from this
model of Suns tanning together in the
English language this word bright is is
interesting it means full of light we
also use it to mean intelligent and
there were alliance has this quality of
being together but also moving in a
direction so what does it mean for
bright Suns to stand together actually
moving in a direction bright alliance so
the Sun metaphor is actually the perfect
setup for him so bred Alliance is and
it's sort of it's been around for a few
years now and mainly its unpublishing
and so publishing is something that I
never thought that I would get into but
it turns to be a really great way to
preserve things so bred Alliance has
recently published to five different
volumes of translations from the Tibetan
can and the bones of Chen it's called
Canon that Dan Brown is translated with
someone named Ke$ha Sonam from the bumpo
tradition and Tibet and this is the only
time these books have been translated
into English and they've been preserved
through this publishing house so that's
one example is you know someone like Dan
and some of these other these Tibetan
teachers publishing work and preserving
work through bred Alliance but in the
past bird alliances than other things
like bread alliance has helped to
facilitate and explore what does it mean
for different people who are looking for
spiritual practice 2.0 so people have
done a lot of their own individual work
they've done their own sort of shadow
work and integration and they instead
a path for a while they have some sense
of this remembering in their lives but
then they come together and what are the
practices that we can do together to
enrich each other that practice 2.0 or
would used to call relational spiritual
practice was something that Brite
Alliance was doing for quite a few years
it's been on break for a while but I
sense that that's coming back you know
another thing that I'm really interested
in doing is pulling together different
teachers across multiple different
lineages in exploring the gifts of each
of those lineages and seeing how they
might contribute to a more global
spirituality or a spirituality that's
based on sort of the best of what we
know about being human historically and
also what's emerging now my sense is
that we're reaching a time in our
evolution as a human species where
they're the individual spiritual teacher
will begin to so unify into groups of
spiritual teachers together across
lineages and cultures I often say that
the individual spiritual teacher or
lineage holder or or realizer
well well sort of always be pushed to
the side and the fringes of culture and
society but when we reach a point in the
arc of our evolution as a human species
where people can come to enough of an
understanding of the deeper spiritual
path they're standing on even as the
surface features remain different when
we get a group with people who can stand
together across traditions across
cultures across lineages and can
actually share in teaching and sharing
humanity's wisdom all at once
there's a way in which that impulse
won't be denied it won't be able to be
ignored on the world stage so for me
Brite Alliance is a seed for the
eventual coming together of a group of
spiritual realizes teachers
practitioners to share what's more of a
universal inheritance of human wisdom
with the world in a really positive way
so who knows I mean that could just be a
pipe dream and I'm okay with that too
but it seems like something aspirational
at the very least that we might stand
together and have benefit for others if
something like that doesn't unfold my
wife is so good at teaching me that the
moment-to-moment experiences that we
have every interaction we have the way
that we interact with the clerk and the
way that we interact with other drivers
on the road the way that we interact
with our
that's really where the rubber meets the
road that's the most important thing if
in addition to that other things unfold
I think that's really positive but
they're not necessary
that's bride alliance yeah the
moment-to-moment practice of spiritual
awakening being the greatest test and
achievement and all in the conduct that
emerges from them well it's Mongkok on
duck that emerges from it yes yes by
their fruits ye shall know them and is
this phrase that's in both the New
Testament and that William James often
quotes and then my teacher Dan Brown
often quotes it's by the fruits you'll
know true realizers by the fruits and
the paths that they leave behind them so
I often say to people who are interested
in beginning to study with somebody or
they wanted tests you know someone's
practice they should look at their
history and notice all of the
relationships and everything that
they've left behind them people of
authentic awakening leave a wake of
goodness in their past no matter where
they've gone there's like I visualize it
I look like like flowers floating behind
some of the other paths yeah and someone
who who is anybody can be you know
fooled in the moment by someone's
charisma and these things and yet to
look at the history so this idea of of
conduct being the true sign of someone's
practice I think is a really good one to
live by look at where someone's been how
they've showed up how they're showing up
now and how they continue to show up and
to go slow with your relationships with
others in your relationships with
teachers in general and also keeping in
mind the evolution of people the
evolution of ethics the evolution of our
spiritual paths because we also have a
phenomenon that's happening where people
are digging like five or ten years in
the past and trying to so happen here
saying that it actually is so
uncompassionate to to go so to go into
someone's history in such a way that
you're not actually seeing them fresh so
there's a balance between seeing history
and being totally open to who somebody
is in this moment seeing them with fresh
eyes and new eyes and that's I think you
know the other pole of knowing someone's
conduct and tracing it back itself
knowing that you're open to them showing
up in a new way for you in this
to who they might have been five minutes
ago and when we balance a fresh
perspective with examining conduct I
think then we have a really good
integration of two views yeah I like
that and I also like bright alliances
understanding that this timeless
spiritual wisdom has been collectively
you can look at the big huge planetary
level of timeless spiritual wisdom
that's been evolving with us over time
and to be able to both preserve it and
innovate with it in the sense of meeting
the information technology age but also
in the sense of making novel connections
between timeless spiritual wisdoms that
have yet to be explored is really
interesting to me - yeah it was like a
very ripe moment in human evolution for
us to be able to do that yeah it's
basically again what I'm going into the
next chapter to do is is that process of
seeing the the timeless collective
wisdoms of of us and then finding
patterns across them trying to find
novel connections across them and then
further disseminate those in novel
metaphors and stories that then can be
further built upon or critiqued or or
may new connections with etc to kind of
evolve us us further okay I would like
to ask you this is probably useful for
me and for others because you referenced
this earlier and this kind of happens a
lot when we say words like indigeneity
where we say a word like Buddhism or
Tibetan Buddhism even they're still
Mahamudra zouk Shen what
are those breakdowns and then you give
us a little insight into that sure well
you know as someone who studied religion
one of the first things I learned was
that these all these categories are
inventions basically invented categories
for convenience of study and the real
lived experience of any of these
different traditions and leage is so
much more rich and dynamic than any of
that so even the north-south-east-west I
mean it's like it's useful for a moment
and then it becomes totally irrelevant
because it's so oversimplified it's not
even useful so same thing when we talk
about these different religious and
spiritual traditions is that they're
complex living organisms that are
constantly changing and evolving okay
with that caveat in place I'll say a
little bit about how I've come to
understand at least Muhammad Renzo chim
so within the Tibetan tradition there
was there are several different main
lineages of practice the highest
teaching in some of those lineages so
one lineage is called the kagu tradition
the highest teaching in that particular
tradition is called Maha mudra maha
means great and mudra means seal or
gesture so a great seal or great gesture
what Maha mudra is really excellent at
is articulating a step by step process
by which one moves from ordinary
consciousness to this unbounded
wholeness or to awakened consciousness
it's extremely effective in doing that
as I've studied with Dan and the
teachings that he's learned from his own
teachers like a shy walking on others
I've learning and training to teach that
I don't have full permission to teach us
I want to be very clear that I'm still
training I'm still you know and I'm
still in a princess ship but mom would
just excellent at that step-by-step path
don'ts that path that we see with that's
different that's called the elephant
path which is a path of concentration
specifically not a path of insight which
leads towards awakening Maha mudra in
particulars use it useful that's that by
step path but Zhongshan is really useful
for us once you have a taste of that
opening or taste of that awakening as
action is excellent at detailed
instructions about how to stabilize that
awakening from moment to moment how to
remember consistently over time Dobson
teachings come from the lingman lineage
which is like the ancient linear the
oldest lineage of the Tibet
cheating's some assumption is very
simple in certain ways in its
articulations but it's not as good at
the step by step unfolding so what Dan's
been able to do in his the way he's
learned these teachings is to synthesize
both maja Mucha and Zog chant in a
really effective way some of the more
advanced doctrine teachings that we've
been learning lately come from the bun
tradition so the enigma tradition is the
tradition of Tibet the bumpo tradition
is a tradition that comes actually from
much further east has different origins
and a different civilization and so the
Sojin teachings we've been learning are
really about stabilizing and completing
the path so if anybody wants the most
basic breakdown the way that I've
learned it is that Muhammad is good at
step by step from ordinary awareness to
your first taste of awakening and
suction is good and how do you stabilize
that Awakening and complete the path to
fall alignment yeah whoa yeah make sense
to draw on both of them as well Dan in a
lot of ways is one of these integralists
where he's looking at the traditions and
he's saying from a practitioners
perspective what does this path do more
effective than this path and how do you
actually bring them all together in
Tibet that was called a tradition called
reemay which means non-sectarian there's
a non sectarian or a trans lineage
perspective yeah it's really useful so
the practice that I've learned from Dan
and the practice of Dan's Todd the
different lamas and teaches we bring in
are all part of that orientation we may
our non-sectarian yeah so we're moving
now into an area of global rimae or
non-sectarian or trans lineage practice
as a human species not just within
Tibetan culture what practices work best
for what aspects of the path but as a
human species what aspects of different
lineages work best for different aspects
of our own unfolding that's what Adi dog
called the great tradition of humankind
we're actually entering into an era
where we actually can stand in one
single human lineage the great
inheritance of wisdom is now here and
available to us no longer divided into
these different branches but actually we
have it all
here and we can in Crete integrate that
into a true translating its path it's
part of your seems like part of your
interest in your destiny
well given our moments now where there's
such abundance in the internet age and
the computational Renaissance that we
can now take time with spiritual wisdom
lineages and we can see how for a union
for every one of us is a unique
combination and also like you said trans
lineage but also getting down to two
water that's why it's translated it
means that you take one really really
deep but you also can move beyond it you
have to stand in something with depth
before you can move beyond it you can't
just sample as we said earlier okay
interesting so part Oh interesting so
part of the of the buffets that one one
bite isn't a really good representation
that if you you you take the full the
full meal in which takes time to take a
full meal and you can taste the buffet
until you decide which meal is the best
fit for your particular orientation then
you have to eat the whole meal once
you've eaten the whole meal you can then
explore other flavors we've eaten the
whole meal your bellies already full
you're not exploring to sort of see
something that's missing you're you're
already full in your own practice your
path you realization yet you might
supplement so that you can fill out
different aspects of the realization or
the practice that you might not have
otherwise been able to fill out within
your single meal the flavors that
weren't in your single meal Seanie both
exactly may I also eat another meal and
go down that so I can maybe eat many
meals your motivation might be different
so when you eat your first meal it's
because you're hungry
and you need food and you need to fill
up your belly with the realization if
you eat a second meal it's not because
you're hungry but you might eat the
second meal out of deep care because you
want more tools to be able to help other
beings so you might want to eat the
second meal because the meal you ate
might not be right for everybody so you
want to eat a second and a third and a
fourth and a fifth meal so that when
someone comes to you and they're hungry
you have the right flavor for them to
fill their belly so that would be the
motivation to eat more than one meal all
right a couple of the last questions
that we like asking I want to hit this
one on the way you've had this process
that you've done now with with Mikey
Segal where you guys host sessions where
you listen to other people's heartbeats
while you look at them in the eyes
yeah but Mikey is such a pioneer I hope
he comes on the show Mikey he hates it
when I say this but it's true Mikey's
gonna be like written into the textbooks
about the evolution of consciousness
when it comes to how technology and
consciousness interface Mike he's
designed something called the group flow
process where we hooked 24 people up to
like a central brain and that central
brain is all sort of coordinated by a
consciousness jockey like a DJ like a CJ
and that CJ can actually play with the
different ways in which different
biometrics are playing out into the
real-time into the space we can play
people's heartbeat through speakers we
can play people's heartbeat through
headphones we can swap heartbeats we
sometimes use breath sensors to breathe
together to harmonize breathing as
collectives and to listen to each
other's breath and it's all translated
into sound into light so one of the
things that we do because you mentioned
it is that we have this amazing practice
where we sit together we listen to our
own heartbeats which in and of itself
can be a profound experience just the
mini has never heard our own heartbeats
we realized wow it's such an intimate
relationship with ourselves and then
what we do is we actually make eye
contact with the other person
and we really ritualize the process of
trading hearts you take a light with
your heart pulsing on it you hand it to
somebody else gently and delicately as
you look at them in the eyes and we have
our CJ our consciousness jockey shift
their heartbeat into your ears so you're
like holding a person's heart in your
hands as its glowing with light you're
looking at them in the eyes and you're
hearing the heartbeat talk about an
incredible way to connect as human
beings so one of my keys thesis is that
if technology is currently being used to
create massive divisions separation of
isolation human species well technology
is neutral so how can we use technology
to actually bring us into deeper
connection and it's a deeper awakening
into deeper intimacy with each other so
anybody who's not familiar with Mikey
sequels work of consciousness sake is
doing amazing work I've had such a fun
time teaching with him and at retreats
every year at Esalen and elsewhere so
that's worth checking out if other
people aren't familiar with that
consciousness hacking Co hack comm you
can find our playlist also with
consciousness hackings awakened future
summit we did partnership interviews
with them you guys can find that
playlist on our channel where we talk to
many of these leaders that are doing
pioneering work you say you know
technology can be used in malevolent
ways can also be used and always
benevolent ways and for us to find the
benevolent ways like this exercise is
gorgeous listening to your heart again
get a 30 or 40 dollar telesco
stethoscope on on any of on Amazon or
any of the other platforms ingest and
listen to your own heartbeat and it'll
and listen to your gut and it changes
your life and then if you can partake in
one of those activities where you can
receive someone's light and lit up heart
and hear their heartbeat like I love the
design of experiences like that because
it cat it's an option on the buffet that
is very new to the technology and age
that can enrich people to want to care
more about the spiritual path
so like technology can be super
conducive to people desiring to get onto
that spiritual path yeah one of the
things that I found I teach a class at
Stanford actually Mikey first started
called technology and meditation and we
always do a survey at the Pinney a class
like who meditates and obviously it's a
self-selected group but like 95 percent
of people have a meditation practice
we asked like who's meditating using an
app and again it's like 80 to 90 percent
of people are meditating because of an
app so technology can bring people onto
the path the coolest thing about that
class is that we give them all this
technology they try it out and at the
end we say who's gonna continue their
meditation practice because we also give
them instruction in class and you know
100 percent of people say they're gonna
continue and say who's gonna continue
with the apps and by that point we've
given them enough instruction but they
don't even need to use the apps anymore
so I see apps and technology as such a
positive on-ramp to get people
interested and hooked for things they
might not have otherwise been interested
in so I'm all for technology and apps as
long as they create an an on-ramp for
deeper practice yeah and how do you see
the way that we have in the harmonic
interconnectedness of our natural
environment we see things like larger
trees sequestering carbon in it in
excess amounts and redistributing that
through their roots and fungal networks
the smaller trees and seedlings that
don't get so much meanwhile in our
wealth inequality we don't see similar
inclusive stake holding frameworks so
how do you see like spiritual evolution
playing a part in the redesign of the
social contract for inclusive stake
holding to have a deeper amount of love
and compassion for the rest of us on the
planet not seeing as an other but seeing
as another as a brother-sister as
another part of this human yeah you know
for most of
of human history never musty mystery
there's I've been a huge segment of
people who are interested in inner work
and for a long time let's just look at
the United States from the 1960s there
was a big group of people who are really
interested in inner work and they sort
of went on meditation retreats they saw
the Beatles studying with Maharishi
Mahesh Yogi and they said oh maybe if I
go inward I can find a way to transform
my own mind and a lot of those people
did have a lot of success going inward
and they actually discovered some things
about their own mind and their own
awareness but often that group of people
was not very impactful in the world also
in the nineteen sixties there was this
birth of people who actually said whoa
look at what's happening in the world
like we have civil rights movement
women's movement environmental movements
beginning they said we really need to
have impact in the world we need to
actually look at the social inequalities
and what's happening we need to do
something to actually make an impact and
change but often that group would see so
many struggles and problems in front of
them that they would end up finding they
would get burnout so what I see
happening right now is this amazing
opportunity for integration where the
people who have spent time going inward
have actually gained some source of
inexhaustible energy and on the external
the people of actually doing the impact
in the world have an opportunity to go
inward and when these two come together
it seems like we have an opportunity for
people to go into the world with extreme
positive impact and a reservoir of
inexhaustible energy for a real change
to happen so I'm really hopeful I think
it's happening now my wife works for a
foundation and and the interest that's
sprouting around inner work and
development is like going you know off
the charts and same thing I'm working
now with Evolved Foundation which is an
organization started by beau Chau and
the the inner work that people are
interested in now is just it's amazing
so I think that we're coming to a place
in our own evolution at least in Western
Maryland culture and Western culture who
we actually see these two streams that
were born in the 1960s of inner work and
outer transformation coming together
into a single River and so I'm really
hopeful I don't know exactly how it's
going to unfold but I do know that that
that with that inner resource of
spiritual awakening and a transcendence
and inclusion of the self so self
compassion but also a much broader
source of social good can bind with like
the tried and true methods of social
change that have been worn through 40 or
50 or now 60 years of social change in
social entrepreneurship I think that we
have the opportunity to see the real
impact that we all want to see so I
don't know how it will play out but I
certainly hope to be a part of it and to
play a role in it and I'm hopeful that
these streams can come together into a
really huge impactful River in the
coming years thank you does it feel like
humanity is a biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence what do you
mean by bootloader and then I answer
your question
I like the question what do you mean by
bootloader are we a stepping stone I
mean my my thing is my experience is
that there's something incredibly
precious about human beings and there's
something incredibly precious about life
itself and as we start to really take
seriously the spiritual path itself I
think that what we start to find is that
these fears of sort of some super
intelligence taking over AI taking over
to me they're externalize anxieties like
we're actually worried about our own
aspects of selfs are taking over in ways
that we aren't able to control and so
what what I think is that we start to
actually see the sacredness of life in
such a way that like no part of reality
is ever instrumentalized or utilized in
a way that has some sort of negative or
malicious intent behind it as I said
earlier I think we can actually start to
see that we're living in a sacred world
and that the intention behind the world
is actually to reveal itself to itself
and when that orientation is present I
don't think that we see ourselves
through this perspective that you're
saying I could have totally not
understood the question - what do you
think I go between the the the these
these are law
yes I see the question I got it was such
a yeah it's humanity a biological
bootloader for digital super
intelligence yes no way no way digital
super intelligence doesn't have an
interior like you know we have basic
understandings that I've learned to
integral theories like we have an
exterior and interior and although no
matter how much a super intelligence
might be able to externally exhibit the
behaviors of empathy and and care and
massive intelligence there's no actually
like in there there and do I think we
may have the capacity to actually to
integrate our particular interior with a
super intelligent you know bio created
super intelligence that consciousness in
that life is so secretive I mean we
might learn how to project our
consciousness outside of our bodies as
many people can do now and live in
different subtle realms and States and
dream states we might be able to learn
how to do that and inject it into a
super consciousness but we would be the
interior that we're injecting so I see a
much more harmonious future than
somewhere yeah we're being used or taken
over for some sort of you know super
intelligence now let's we integrate with
it which should be may is source giving
us free will so that it can dance with
uncertainty and that we can be artists
of the symphony that's unfolding I think
this is a good question for the users
and the viewers to contemplate for
themselves I don't want to give an
answer to it this question around free
will and determinism is one that goes so
deep and there's probably ways in which
it's that both sides are true
and I find just the inquiry itself to be
extremely extremely tenth elating yeah
that's really a cool question but I'm
not gonna go there and say I don't want
to give an answer to that another
interesting point along it is that the
more spiritually awake and woke we are
that the less spiritually fragmented we
are and the more spiritually fragmented
we are it seems like the less freewill
we have because we can have other forces
be at play from the Tibetan point of
view that I've learned there's there's
always intention and that there's
intention and that intention of
individual intention begins to just
become more and more transparent to a
universal intention and that universal
intention is to awaken itself to itself
and from that perspective do we say that
it's free well it's determinism and I do
come down on the side of like the
universe is trying to reveal itself to
itself every moment like even this one
yes everybody listening between you and
I it's trying to reveal itself saying
hey do you recognize that we're actually
the exact same awareness looking at each
other yeah you know so who knows yes is
this are we on the DAO are we on the
path have we veered off and we need to
come back on how do you view that yeah
each individual is finding the way more
and more fully onto the path but it's
not that they veered off the path is
that they're recognizing more and more
clearly that they've always been on the
path so there's a difference between
sort of you know in the early Christian
tradition is there such a thing as off
path then from the perspective of the
individual who is actually living in
forgetting they feel like they're off
path yes they feel like they're off path
if they're actually on path towards
becoming more on path yes because that's
the nature of reality is that it's
actually bringing us all on to a deeper
realization that we're all on path
already there's something primordial
about being on the path
yes and it certainly feels a lot of the
time you know for many people that
they're not on the path you know I want
to offer something and that's that in
the early interpretations of the word
sin in the Christian tradition the early
Greek may be alieve had other guests to
say this to you but the idea of sin was
to miss the mark right it's like the you
just you were shooting an arrow and it
was just a bit off but that means you
can redirect so I really like about this
idea of like being on the path it's just
like can you remember a moment a moment
the moment you remember you're right
back on path you haven't missed the mark
but you missed the mark every time you
forget every time you forget that there
actually is a goodness underlying all of
reality that's bringing things forth for
you it's a much larger discussion which
maybe you've even had with Jordan Peters
and another is about sort of the nature
of evil and these kind of things but I
think there's a perspective we can take
where it can be totally inclusive of
both the relative nature of good and
evil and simultaneously this perspective
that everything is actually unfolding in
a beautiful way of the great perfection
result Jen yeah
and then what do you feel is most
beautiful
I want to give like a personal answer
and a bit more of a philosophical answer
those off because it's more dry than
personal philosophical I was so moved
with first I read Plato's symposium and
the symposium Socrates gives us amazing
articulation of what sometimes been
called the ladder of love and he says
you know I've been a paraphrase and you
know butchered a bit but basically idea
is that we begin by appreciating beauty
in like another human being and we see
that beauty another human being maybe
it's in there like naked form and which
is in awe about beauty and then what
happens is that we see another form and
we actually say well there's something
beautiful about that too so we begin to
realize there must be some transcendent
principle beauty that exists both in
this form and in this form so something
higher and then we begin to say well
it's not only bodies that are beautiful
there's something about like the way in
which we can come up with you know
mathematical formations and philosophy
and like wow that's beauty that's
beautiful too and then as much as that
but it's the ways that we can build
philosophical systems the govern society
and you know that's beautiful too and we
just move along this ladder of beauty or
this ladder of love ladder of lust after
beauty until we finally reach this this
culmination of coming face to face with
Beauty itself and in the realization of
beauty itself it's like we begin to see
that like reality itself it's so
unbelievably beautiful in that ladder of
realization that ladder of love is one
that's been so deeply close to my heart
and just to bring it into the micro like
the process of being a father and having
children and watching my wife for like
60 hours just I give everything she had
and I give life to another human being
yeah I mean that's beautiful yeah that's
really beautiful so the whole is
beautiful and the smallest most my new
particular experience is beautiful and
we find Beauty through and through
oh thank you mother thank you for that
time and the questions and your care
thanks for coming on the show for
sharing with us
it's been beautiful it's such a joy true
pleasure thank you thank you thank you
well thank you thank you thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the conversation now
we had today let us know should thinking
have more conversations to your friends
families co-workers people online about
the subjects that Dustin covered in the
show about all things timeless spiritual
wisdom have more conversations about
that have more practices about that
check out the links in the bio below
again Dustin's website also his book
links check those out
also the credible mine comm credible
mine calm as well and support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders in your communities around the
world support them help them grow and
support us simulation our links are
below to our show PayPal patreon
cryptocurrency support us and go and
architect that future social fabric for
Prosperity we love you very much thank
you for tuning in we will see you soon
meditation on the way out that's okay
yeah okay sure so short short letter
short short meditation on the way all
right well great so just take a moment
to sit up straight in the matter where
you are and take a deep breath in
filling your belly
and feel your hands you take your hands
and place them against your thighs or
your knees and just begin to explore the
boundaries between where your hands end
and your thighs begin can you find the
boundary or the edge between your hands
and your eyes
and then bringing your attention now
it's your whole body feeling your whole
body all at once from the inside out so
rather than jumping around from
different parts of your body like your
head your foot your knee just feeling
your body as a whole then begin to feel
the air against your skin and your
clothing against your skin
where does your body end and the air
begin can you find the edges or the
boundaries between your body and the air
just allowing your body to glow up down
right left forward and back just the
glowing body opening with feeling no
edges no boundaries
and just rest in this open awareness
totally present with everything has each
moment unfolds
just radiating with awareness
okay maintain this feeling and just go
about your day oh you're a knight thank
you brother
yeah
moment-to-moment that thank you thank
you thank you thanks so much